when you look at the topic of immigration
from a world history point of view,
you very quickly realize that racial and religious
minorities in places like the United States and Europe
have historically been discriminated against,
scapegoated for the country's problems,
not wanted, not desired,
treated like invaders,
etc. however,
in countries like Argentina,
this concept was flipped on its head.
when it has been Europeans who are doing the migrating,
it is encouraged for them to do so.
many people often question
why is Argentina seemingly such a white country
with virtually no black people,
no indigenous people,
no diversity whatsoever?
when you think about it,
Argentina has historically taken
pride in its European heritage.
from 1850 to 1950,
there was a mass migration of
7,000,000 Europeans to Argentina,
mostly Spanish and Italian.
an old saying in the country even says that
Mexicans come from the Aztecs,
Peruvians from the Incas,
but Argentinians descend from the ships.
but of course,
this is historically inaccurate
and the marketing of Argentina as a country of
transplant European immigrants is completely false,
starting with the black
population that the country has historically had.
during argentina's colonial period,
200 000 African slaves descended on the country,
and by the end of the 18th century,
1/3 of the population of the country was black.
however, argentina's white governmental leaders
in the early days of its development as a country
crafted a narrative in which they were
going to completely erase any history of blackness.
within the country,
Domingo Falsetino Sarmiento,
ex President of Argentina,
crafted a different narrative to erase blackness
because they equated modernity with whiteness,
when in reality
Argentina has been home to many
black people for centuries,
not only the
population of enslaved people and their descendants,
but immigrants
from different areas of Africa and Europe,
who also entered the nation in larger numbers
during the thirties and forties,
seeking employment as Mariners and dock workers.
white Argentinian diplomats at the time
also wanted to promote
white European immigration to the country.
Argentinian President Husta Jose de Ruquisa
supported these diplomats ideas
and incorporated them into the country's
first constitution.
amendment 25 of said constitution
clearly stated
the federal government
shall foster European immigration.
one of these presidents even said
20 years hence
it will be necessary to travel to Brazil
to see black people.
he knew that black Argentines existed,
but suggested that the country
would not recognize them for long.
and that amendment
that European immigration is encouraged to Argentina
is still in the constitution of the country today.
so please ignore the marketing of those racist
white politicians
and remember that there are Afro Argentines
and indigenous Argentines
that still live within the country to this day.